good afternoon it being one o'clock I'll
call the
the fiscal committee to order for our
March 24 2023 meeting
the first item on the agenda is
acceptance of the minutes on Tab one
move to approve
Senator gray moves to approved Senator
Dallas Andrews seconds
does anyone have any change to the
amendment to the minutes seeing Nani
ready for the question all in favor say
aye aye opposed no
the minutes are adopted
moving on to the Tab 2 is empty tab we
have a
consent calendar that goes all the way
from Tab 3 through tab nine I have
requests to remove under Tab 4 item
fis079 under tab 6 FIS
23-099 and under Tab 8 FIS
23082 are there any other
items to be removed from the consent
calendar
under Tab 4
-079
under tab six
zero nine nine
and under tab eight
zero eight two
made the motion of supplements
Senator gray Senator D'Alessandro
I'll entertain a motion to adopt the
rest of the consent calendar
motion by Senator Bradley second by
Senator D'Alessandro to approve the
other items on the consent calendar
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
the consent calendar is adopted we'll go
to Tab four
and item fis079
and that's the Department of Education
and we welcome commissioner edelblue
good morning or good afternoon for the
record Frank gator blue Commissioner of
Education
Tammy valencourt CFO for education
Senator Rose
Senator rosenblatt is recognized from a
question thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon commissioner Tammy
um my understanding is that the this
grant
um ends next year
and so my question is what's what is an
apartment's plan to continue this system
of care work
beyond the period of the Federal grant
is it in the budget or
um how how will we continue the work so
there are appropriation requests that
are included in the budgeting process
but as well we will seek both no cost
extensions as well as reapply for the
grant
um some of parts of the grant program
are continuing on and we will seek and
apply for those from the federal
government
thank you
Senator bird cell for a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um also in the same
um where it says increasing family
engagement and expanding professional
development what type of professional
development are are we so most of the
professional development around the
system of care Grant is in our mtssb
work which is multi-tier System of
support behavioral setup and so
essentially what we're doing is we're
working specifically with school
districts there are seven districts in
the program right now where we help them
develop uh relationships and really a
framework to interconnect with the
community around them to provide
supports to students the way that mtssb
works is we have Universal support So at
the lowest level and that's kind of
every student needs some degree of
support I like to describe it as we have
to teach kids not to stick their gum
under the table and then it escalates
from there level two is kids who maybe
need some more support and then up to
level three which is generally where
we're referring them outside of the
school system to get support and by
building that mtssp kind of Coalition of
both the school and the community we're
able to more seamlessly interconnect
those students to support services great
thank you
Senator Rosenwald moves approval Senator
gray seconds is there any further
discussion I have a motion to approve
the item
all those in favor say aye
oppose no
and we have adopted FIS
uh zero seven nine moving on to tab six
and we'll be looking at item zero eight
two
or zero nine nine excuse me FIS
23099 and that's the department of
energy who we have to answer the
questions from energy please introduce
yourself welcome to the fiscal
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record Josh
Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs Department of energy
commissioner chicoine sends his
apologies he's actually at a regional
meeting in Massachusetts today
thank you
Senator Rosenwald is recognized for a
question great to see you back likewise
Senator
um so we're accepting another 16 million
dollars I'm just wondering
how many more households and
how much more money per household will
we be able to
help Granite Staters with sure
um so if uh looking at just sort of the
average numbers that we've seen so far
this season currently the average
benefit has just been shy of two
thousand dollars per household there is
a matrix that determines the actual
amount that any particular household
will receive based on income based on
fuel type as well as
household size as well so rather than
depending on how much money we get it's
dependent on a number of other factors
that is within those matrices so if we
were to say okay assume that every
single uh you know we were to see
additional enrollment to eat up this
entire fund uh this entire appropriation
of the extra 60 16 million it would
cover about 8 400 additional households
assuming um everybody was in at the
average benefit of just less than two
thousand dollars
further questions from committee members
Senator bird cell moves to approve FIS
23099 and
Senator Rosenwald seconds further
discussion
seeing 90 ready for the question the
motion is to approve 099 all in favor
say aye aye opposed no the item is
adopted
fis082
dealing with the Department of
administrative services
and we see commissioner arlinghaus
coming forward
hi uh I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commissioner of administrative services
and you are
hi I'm Karen ranchimacki director of
plant and property
thank you Senator Rosenwald is
recognized for a question thank you I
feel like Bad Bunny
um so as I was reading this item
last year when we started it it was for
ventilation improvements
but now it seems like you want to
repurpose the funds
for building envelope which I think must
mean the outside of the building
um Paving
life safety
hyping
and improvements to Interior spaces have
have we decided that ventilation is all
good no we're not even close
um we're still very Pro ventilation and
as you know many of the state buildings
have
let's just put it mediocre ventilation
and and my understanding is we still
consider fresh air to be a good thing
um and um there are actually two
separate arpa items and they're the one
of them you approved this transfer for
last month
when I was not here and you got to talk
to Sherry about it I think Karen too but
I'm not positive
um and that's that that is strictly
speaking for HVAC sort of issues this
item is a is a this item is a separate
item the description refers to both of
them but this item is the non-hvac stuff
and so they're each about 20 million
give or take and the item last month was
all the HVAC because it's a separate
arpa category I believe that because
there's a specifically called out in
arpa where this is just sort of General
deferred maintenance around the state so
this is think of this item as non-hvac
and the old item the item from last
month as HVAC
HVAC meaning ventilation the V is for
ventilation just oh please further
question thank you it's Friday afternoon
I'm struggling so
uh there were two different items one
was for ventilation one was for General
repairs but the explanation refers to
both of them yes and that was a and
that's probably something we shouldn't
have done okay but got it thank you
thank you Mr chairman
further questions from the committee
senator
Senator bird sale moves approval
second by Senator Rosenwald
any further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question to approve item uh
23082 all in favor say aye aye opposed
no that motion carries we'll move on to
tab ten
in the regular calendar the first item
is 23086
Department of Health and Human Services
are there any questions on the item
Senator Rosenwald thank you
welcome Mr White
good afternoon Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer
good afternoon Ellen Lapointe CEO at New
Hampshire hospital thank you
um so this item is
short-term Staffing contracts it's my
understanding that we have like
30 or so beds at New Hampshire hospital
that were not able to
operate because we don't have Staffing
well this money allow us to reopen those
beds so that New Hampshire hospital will
be running at full capacity
thank you for the question Senator and I
wish I could tell you the answer was yes
but no unfortunately this money won't
further assist us in opening additional
beds the reason for that is because this
money is actually a request to
reallocate funding for the expenses that
we've already incurred for our agency
and temporary staff to be able to make
those line items whole
thank you for that has the department
looked at
making a bigger transfer so that we
could
open up all the beds and get people out
of emergency departments or would that
mean you couldn't make your laps
so I I think there's two elements to
this and and I'll defer to to Ellen on
the on the hiring
um there are challenges with hiring the
nurses and the social workers and and
other key positions at New Hampshire
hospital right now so even if we were to
transfer funds for personnel there would
be challenges there and then Ellen I
don't know if you want to speak to the
to the wings as well
yes thank you again senator for the
question so um in terms of work that's
being done to address the the closed
beds at New Hampshire hospital it's very
much a priority on behalf of the
hospital as well as the department and
we're working on several plans in order
to try to expedite that and make it a
top priority so that we can reopen those
beds however an additional concern that
has happened within the last several
weeks is when we had that very cold
weather back in February there was a
sprinkler head that burst in New
Hampshire hospital and thankfully the
week prior to that we had vacated those
two sister units in their entirety and
that's where the open beds at New
Hampshire hospital currently reside
however it caused a significant amount
of damage at those locations that
required a significant amount of
demolition so from a staffing
perspective we have concerns and now
from an environmental perspective we
also have significant concerns in that
space
well
for the questions from committee members
Senator Dallas Andrew thank you Mr
chairman uh with with regard to those
beds we appropriate it buddy in the last
Pioneer to do the transition from where
the young kids were to where adults were
how how have how how far have we
progressed in terms of could that
conversion situation because that was to
create 40 40 additional meds
so thank you for the question Senator I
just want to clarify are you talking
about the renovation that we that was
approved funding was approved for a
renovation of those two units I'm
talking about yes the money that we
allocated to take the the rooms that the
children were occupying and to convert
them to adult beds there were 20 of
those and uh when you converted them to
adult we created 40 more spaces thank
you for clarifying that question for me
so I understood so at the time
um that the beds that the children were
in were vacated during covid we did
actually without having pursued the
renovation at that time
Implement those beds for Adult Services
so um at the peak of covet our maximum
census was approximately 184.
um since then we've lost significant
Staffing which has yielded the need to
close those units
and have the deficit of 31 beds that we
have currently
okay thank you thank you Mr chairman
further questions about the item from
any committee members
I'll entertain a motion to approve
motion to approve from Senator Rosenwald
second by Senator dallasandra to adopt
item
23086 any further discussion seeing Nani
are ready for the question all in favor
say aye
aye opposed no the item is adopted
moving on to tab 11 and item 23090
Department of Safety
any questions on this item Senator
Rosenwald
thank you
um
good afternoon Steve Lavoy director of
administration hi Steve thank you Mr
chairman so it seems to me if I ended up
like we're spending about over six
hundred thousand dollars a year in
credit card fees
at the DMV is that
reimbursing for do we
charge a convenience fee to customers
who are using their credit cards
we do not and that's what these expenses
represent these are the costs that the
department pays the merchant service
providers for accepting payment by
credit card we don't currently charge a
convenience fee
um that would be another alternative to
covering some of these costs could I
follow up would you have the statutory
authority to do that we do have the
statutory Authority yes
okay why aren't you doing yeah I mean
why are we losing money so it's your
customer convenience It's a combination
of both a business decision and a
budgetary decision
um if if we don't have the funding in
our budget to cover these costs we're
really forced as a department to
implement a convenience fee
when online transactions were first
introduced at the DMV we really wanted
to encourage people to move in that
direction and so at the time convenience
fees were viewed as a deterrent to doing
so if there's an additional cost
um to processing online times have
changed and now it's common for
convenience fees to be assessed and so
um again it's really a combination of of
a business and a budgetary decision uh
whether or not we would continue to move
forward with with that practice at this
point
um we wouldn't be in a position to make
that change this fiscal year and we've
been having those discussions with house
finance division two as far as moving it
forward
okay thank you I'm sure we'll have
discussions in the Senate as well
Senator de Alessandro for a question
thank you thank you Mr Jim first of all
Stevie congratulations
your elevation
thank you assistant Commission of the
department but with regard to the fee
Steve it it seems to be in today's world
everyone
that accepted the credit cards as
charging that fee and I I see it all the
time when I go to a restaurant that they
add additional three percent if you use
the current
so we're really remiss if if we're not
on top of that and when you look at
these numbers uh this represents a lot a
lot of money a significant amount of
money
so I I know with the Senate we'll be
looking at at that
I look at the the two move movers
and Shake it's here the trio right and
so the five of us are here The Three
Amigos and and us two will be looking at
that thank you Mr chairman
representative Edwards for a question uh
thank you this wasn't my topic Mr chair
but I I just would say that I eat out a
lot these days unfortunately no home
cooking for me I don't see a three
percent credit card fee the only time I
see it is in the state cafeteria
downstairs sir or or when I go to my
Auburn uh town to do dog fees you know I
I I'm okay with government not slapping
a extra transaction on I I would assume
that we have uh advantages to making
sure that our cash flow that we're not
having uh shrinkage in our cash
collections if we have everything
electronic it's it's a for our
convenience I would think
address that
um
at the particular restaurants that I go
to I've seen the three percent addressed
all the time uh and uh
and I think more and more and more as as
cards are becoming the way to do
business a very few people have cash I
know my kids don't know that cash exists
uh they get you know wallets full of
credit cards I never had a credit card
so I uh the three percent didn't bother
me until I got one but I think it's it's
it's the rule of thumb as we speak
around the state
so you're lucky you're very fortunate if
if it's not happening McDonald's is just
not missing they had missed out I guess
we'll catch up later
improve further discussion from the
committee Senator gray moves to approve
the item uh zero nine zero who was the
second
Senator Bradley seconds further
discussion on the item
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no the item is adopted moving on
in the same tab to
23102 Department of Transportation
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee Andre Briere Deputy
Commissioner on hdot
Danielle chanternay Director of Finance
sorry direct uh Danielle chanternay uh
Director of Finance
very good
any questions from the committee members
but Senator dallasandra thank you uh it
seems to me that we make this every year
you come to us every year for this
transfer why don't we just appropriate
properly well we're building the budget
rather than come here for it for for a
transfer
it would not hurt our feelings sir but
uh that that is the way we're budgeting
yes sir it just it just seems to be
every year we we come if we if we if we
do this and that's it's
wasted paper well it's a different every
year sometimes we have a terrible winter
and they might come in for twice as much
sometimes we have a nice winter and they
don't need to move much so but they're
always coming in I know but I credit
them with being very accurate at what
the costs are right that's what I always
look for and people working on money yes
sir we we do try the uh the variability
of of winters does change our requests
if you recall we were here not too long
ago
um the recent storm events that
continued higher use of uh rented trucks
and the increased material costs uh
inflation is is why we're back
I won't knock on wood but but uh
hopefully uh we're we're winding down
representative leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman some of us
unfortunately don't live in the big city
like Manchester but where I live we got
like 35 inches of snow and Peterborough
just to yes sir a week or two ago we
still have some left but I did have a
question if I could miss a chair on um
the class 20 item on page two you
mentioned the anti-icing materials you
use I know you're using the salt and was
it uh brine are you using anything else
that may be less environmentally
sensitive because I've heard from
Peterborough even and people rather in
my area that have had some salt
contamination issues or you moving to
other things like I hear nitrogen is
sometimes used now there are sensitive
we also use sand in some areas but I do
have our operations uh experts here if
uh Mike do you wanna Michael Allen
they can tell you about other things
we've looked at we do look at an
extensive range of materials
Balance cost and environmental impact of
all those materials but we're
continually testing
um Alan uh go ahead and introduce
yourself good afternoon
good afternoon Alan Hanscom State
Highway Maintenance engineer we do we
have experimented with uh different
chemicals at various times potassium
acetate and others comes at a
significant cost increase
um to uh
almost an order of magnitude at times so
we would be here more often
if we did switch that over but it's it's
a significant cost of uh four to five
dollars per gallon versus uh
uh 85 dollars a ton for salt so we we
have we have tried and
um but we didn't find it cost effective
for the question I could thanks Mr
chairman I guess I'm just concerned
because we hear more and more about
water contamination in my division
division one and the cost that that's
now
um basically bearing down on the state
with the requests we're getting from the
Department of Environmental Services so
I'm just that's the way I guess I'm
asking the question because
there may be significant savings by
using the more cheaper salt but the
long-term effect down the road and I do
have one
follow up if I could Mr chairman on
you noted in class 22 again on the
second page that that is going up
obviously because of the outside
contractors but have you seen a decline
in the uh
Highway Maintenance Bureau to offset
what you're asking for for additional
funding because you have to hire so many
contractors right
sir I mean at the moment this is due to
vacancy vacancies this is not an optimal
situation
hired trucks we have always used and
will continue to use because we staff
for summer we don't staff for winter
maintenance otherwise we'd have a lot of
excess staff during the non-winter
months so the higher trucks are used to
to fill that Delta
um our vacancy rate comes at an
opportunity cost
routine maintenance things like Bridge
washing other things that extend the
life of our infrastructure aren't being
done because of our vacancy rate right
now so reducing head count in that case
would would just further exacerbate that
situation and and in our view at least
lead to a long-term degradation of our
transportation infrastructure
I guess my question wasn't clear I'm
sorry Mr chairman I'm further question
wondering where you said that uh I
understand the vacancy rates and
everybody is having that problem but
have you seen a large drop in your
maintenance Bureau budget
obviously if you're not doing all these
things I would guess it'd be a
corresponding drop in expense
yeah Danielle did you want to come up
just moments are I'll let Danielle take
that question
I'm sorry sir I didn't hear the question
could you repeat the question for me
thank you on page two class 22 it was
mentioned that you know we all know
about the vacancy rate and all the
Departments but I was just curious if
the
line had changed significantly within
your Highway Maintenance Bureau as far
as expenses because of that
vacancy rate and not being able to
assist assistant commissioner said wash
Bridges and do other maintenance is that
for the class 22 for a class 22 that's
specific for specifically for the rented
equipment the reason why there's been
such a change in that in addition to the
vacancy rate is the fuel surcharge
that's paid because it's also tied to
the fuel fluctuations that are occurring
I guess I'm having trouble Mr chairman
yes I'm just looking at the yeah again
have you seen a mark decline in the
Highway Maintenance Bureau budget
because of the lack no if you're having
lower miles on some of the trucks is it
saving you yeah some of the other costs
no sir our trucks are are fully utilized
due to our volunteers
so uh it's an all hands on deck effort
right now with regard to Winter
maintenance I I think I get what you're
saying sir I
and the answer would be no we're not
seeing that because uh those uh those
Personnel are being utilized and
primarily it's a Personnel cost that
would
decrease the the actual material cost of
Maintenance of a of a bridge itself is
absorbed in other activities
thank you thank you Mr chairman
further questions on item 23102
Senator Bradley moves the item
who made the second year
Senator gray second
the adoption of FIS 23102 is there any
further discussion on the items seeing
none are you ready for the question all
in favor say aye opposed no the item is
adopted thank you
moving on to tab
13.
or no next item is
we have 12 item is
23073 the judicial Council
good afternoon my name is Richard
samparrell I'm the acting executive
director
are there any questions on item 23073
from the committee members
second
Senator D'Alessandro moves to it to
approve item 23073 Senator Bradley
seconds further discussion seeing none
he ready for the item all in favor say
aye aye opposed no the item is adopted
and we also have while you're sitting
there item
23074 again from the judicial Council
and yet
Senator Alessandro moves to approve
is there a second representative Heath
seconds
further discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye
oppose no that item is adopted
thank you
I have 13 we'll be looking at item
23091 from Department of Corrections
she's been waiting all this time
welcome commissioner Hanks thank you sir
uh for the record Helen Hanks
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections and to my left is Paula
Mattis our director of medical and
forensic services
item 23093 are there any questions from
committee members senate representative
leishman
I was going to move the item but I see
rep Senator Rosenwald as a question
all right then Senator Rosenwald moves
the item Senator leachmann seconds to
approve item 23091 for the
question
oh hang on hang on
Senator Rosenwald is recording thank you
thank you Mr chairman commissioner
um
what is the budget
gonna look like for the next year are
you going to be back here asking for
extra money to pay providers or did we
budget at a higher rate
and I'm sure for the house members they
already know all this but we don't
Senator Roswell I appreciate that
question talking about the end of this
fiscal year this is amount this amount
we're asking for today is to make us
whole for this fiscal year we were at a
disadvantage when we forecasted the last
biennium budget because we did not know
how much contracted a medical Provider
Services were going to cost and that
makes up a large portion this ask we
have that information in the budget we
have before the house and soon to be
before the Senate so we feel very
confident in those numbers and I'm
careful when I say that but we feel very
confident in those numbers
further questions from the committee
Senator bird cell moves approval
Senate Dalessandro's second approval of
item 23091 is there any further
discussion
seeing none
you ready for the question all in favor
say aye I oppose no that item is adopted
moving on to item
23092 Department of administrative
services
are there any questions on item 23092
from the committee
seeing none I'll entertain a motion to
approve
all right I had two motions uh Senator
Bradley second by Senator Rosenberg
Rosenwald further discussion seeing
nunny ready for the question all those
in favor say aye opposed no the item is
approved
moving on to tab 13.
14 tab 14.
first item is
23072 again Department of Corrections
back again
are there any questions on this item
move the item
representative leishman moves the item
for approval
representative Heath seconds
approve the item any further discussion
from the committee members seeing none
are you ready for the question all in
favor say aye aye opposed no that item
is adopted
finishes a regular calendar
were there any questions on any of the
information materials while we have all
all these uh
people here from all the Departments
seeing none I'll recognize uh Stephen
Smith's from the audit division
Mr chairman
um Mike Kane over here representative
Wilder
if you wanted to make a motion to accept
the audits place them on file and
release them to the public in the usual
manner now before the presentations uh
feel free to do so but I'll leave that
up to you
okay
Senator uh gray moons that we accept the
oddest place them on file and release in
the usual Manner and Senator Rosenwald
seconds that and now we will have the
presentation
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
Steve Smith director of audits for the
for the LBA our first audit to present
is the performance audit for the
weatherization assistance program
with me from our office is John clinch
he's the senior audit manager and the
in-charge manager on this this audit and
joining us in the department division
director Josh Elliott so with that I'll
have John present the audit and then go
from there
welcome
thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is John clinch
I'm a senior audit manager with the
office of legislative budget assistant
and I was the auditor in charge for this
audit the weatherization assistance
program
uh which I'm here to present today
as shown on the transmittal letter on
Roman numeral one
the objective of our audit was to
determine if the weatherization
assistance program was efficiently and
effectively overseeing Community Action
agencies weatherization services
our audit period was primarily State
fiscal year 2022 when the legislature
placed it under the department of energy
which is known here as the New Hampshire
is New Hampshire energy
please turn to our executive summary on
page one
we found New Hampshire Energy's
monitoring program was generally
effective and the program had exceeded
its expected Statewide number of
dwellings weatherized in two of the
three state fiscal years for which we
requested Federal reports
the program functions primarily in an
oversight and Grant Management role
while the Community Action agencies
qualify and serve clients based on
federal statutes regulations and program
guidelines
We Believe with a new administrative
support provided by New Hampshire energy
and implementing our recommendations the
program appears to be well positioned to
improve its operating efficiency and
Effectiveness which will be especially
important as it receives an additional
18.2 million dollars from the federal
bipartisan infrastructure law through
the end of State fiscal year 2027.
our recommendation summary starts on
page three
our report had six observations and the
department of energy fully concurred
with all recommendations no observations
will require legislative action
our background section begins on page
five
it contained a brief description of the
weatherization assistance program
including the program's organization and
structure an overview of the
weatherization process and a discussion
of the program monitoring oversight and
expenditures
the next section begins on page 13 and
contained our observations and
recommendations related to information
management
in observation number one we found the
program could be operated more
efficiently and effectively with an
information system specifically designed
and operated to support the
weatherization assistance program
we recommended New Hampshire energy work
with the Department of Information
Technology to ident to identify the
requirements of an information system
that will better support the program
develop or purchase a system that will
meet these unique requirements and
immediately staff establish a secure
method of receiving monthly requests for
reimbursements and supporting
documentation from Community Action
agencies
in observation number two on page 15.
we recommended New Hampshire energy
develop and Implement records management
system that will enable the program to
organize its records for efficient
oversight and program reporting
in observation number three on page 16
we found the weather's weatherization
program was able to report to the U.S
department of energy the number of
dwelling units were completed for every
quarter but it did not track which
community community action agencies
completed the audits
we recommended the program track the
number of completed dwelling units by
each Community Action Agency
turning to the program operations
chapter on page 19
observation number four discussed the
need for administrative rules
we recommended New Hampshire energy
consult with the Department of Justice
and the official office of legislative
services on whether rules are needed for
aspects of the program being implemented
and managed through contracts between
the program and Community Action
agencies
observation number five on page 21
discussed the need for periodic risk
assessment and recommended establishing
formal written written risk assessments
to be used for planning budgeting and
implementing program improvements
finally observation number six begins on
page 22.
it discussed the need to keep public
information updated on its website
during the audit period the program
changed its household income eligibility
limits yet it did not change information
in all places on its website
the appendices are found in the tab
section of the report included our scope
objective and methodology
and New Hampshire Energy's response to
our audit
before I conclude my prepared remarks
I'd like to thank the New Hampshire
energy for its assistance during the
audit
uh with your permission I'd like to turn
it over to Josh Elliott director of
policy and programs
thank you energies comments uh good
afternoon Mr chairman members of the
committee again Josh Elliott director of
the division of policy and programs
again uh commissioner coin being at a
meeting Massachusetts unable to attend
um but sends his apologies
um first and foremost we'd like to thank
the LBA audit division for their
thorough review of this program as well
as their patience at certain points we
were working on filing uh applications
for those additional federal funds and
they were very lenient in terms of our
turnaround times and getting them
documents so just want to again thank
them for their for their consideration
um as uh as mentioned the department
concurs with all of six of the
recommendations
of that the lva audit had suggested for
the program I'm happy to either take
questions or walk through the specific
actions that the department has taken to
address each of these recommendations
have you had discussions with
information technology to come up with a
timeline and a cost
thank you for the question yes so there
is an item contained within House Bill
25 the capital budget we have a request
for a data management system that would
not only cover this program but the
existing fuel assistance program as well
as the electric assistance program
um so that's working its way through
um at the process so we expect to speak
to the house Public Works colleagues and
Senate capital budget Committee in the
next couple weeks about the project
further questions from the committee
representative Edwards do you have a
order of magnitude cost on that system
that database management system
so we have gotten initial quotes
um back last year during the initial
stage of the capital budget process
um we're looking at a roughly around
eight hundred thousand dollars again in
the interim we are looking at just
getting updated quotes just to make sure
we have the best and latest most
up-to-date information especially given
inflation a number of other factors
involving with software costs over the
course of a year
but that sort of gives a ballpark of
what the software costs would be for the
entire program of not only of the
weatherization assistance program but of
uh the fuel assistance program as well
as the electric assistance program
thanks for all the help to the people
that needed it
any further discussion on the item
all right I guess we're going to approve
them all in one
in one vote
what should we move on to next thank you
gentlemen uh
director Smith which we move on to next
we'll move on to our management letters
these are a byproduct of our financial
audits for both Lottery and liquor but
first up will be the Lottery Commission
from our office Kim Bisson she was the
senior audit manager on this and joining
us I believe is director McIntyre and
Jim Durst CFO for from Lottery
Commission welcome
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Kimberly Bisson and I am a senior
audit manager with the LBA division
audit division
I am here today to present the
management letter which is a byproduct
of our audit of the Lottery's fiscal
year 2022 financial statements which
were previously presented to the
committee at the January 27th meeting
if you turn to the table of contents you
will see that the report includes two
internal control observations
none of which were identified as
material weaknesses and it also includes
one-state compliance observation
the lottery concurs with all three
comments and the state compliance
observation suggests legislative action
may be required
the observations begin on page three
observation number one recommends
Lottery strengthen its internal control
procedures over ilottery Revenue
reconciliations
we recommend that the lottery review its
current Revenue reconciliation
procedures and work with the vendor to
ensure that all relevant data points
using the reconciliation are agreed to
valid supporting documentation
we also recommend that Lottery support
its existing reconciliation procedures
with a formal management approved policy
and procedure document
turning to page four
observation number two recommends that
Lottery Implement procedures to ensure
that it's gaming system vendor provides
routine and timely updates to the
listing of individuals used to identify
ineligible players as required by game
rules or contract
finally the state compliance observation
on page six recommends that Lottery
continue to take steps towards
developing and adopting administrative
rules relative to qualifications for
enhanced penalties in accordance with
statute it also recommends Lottery
consult with the Attorney General's
office to determine whether a statutory
revision is necessary to address
conflicting statutory language regarding
the establishment of the investigative
and compliance division
the appendix located behind the tab on
page seven reports the current status as
of December 19 2022
of the observations contained in the
fiscal years 2021 and 2020. Lottery
Commission management letters as noted
on page nine four comments were fully
resolved and three were in the process
of remediation
this conclude concludes my presentation
I would like to thank lotteries
management and staff for their
assistance and cooperation during the
audit and with your permission I will
now turn the presentation over to
director McIntyre for any comments he
may have
thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman
um members of the committee I'm Charlie
McIntyre the privilege being director of
the New Hampshire Lottery with me is our
Chief Financial Officer Jim Durst I also
want to thank the good Folks at LBA for
their hard work and effort on this it's
a remarkably collaborative process it
has been ongoing since I've been here
and certainly before us and so it's a
useful exercise and when we don't enjoy
but certainly it's worthwhile
um and happy to answer any questions you
you folks may have Mr chairman members
committee
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair this is probably a question for
whoever wrote the report on page seven
eight nine there's a status indicator
with uh some dots filled in some not I I
don't see a key so I don't know what
those status bullets mean
it's on page nine
at the bottom
oh there's the key yep
good job
and I guess
I guess Lottery still survives as the
most audited group in the in the State
uh yes we hold that title many years in
a row
proudly giving them their own space yet
Yes actually we do there's a we have an
office for them because yes we have
office space for them
very good further questions from
committee members
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr members congratulations on the
good results
thank you
I guess we'll hear next from liquor
thank you Mr chairman
yes the last one will be a measurement
letter for the Liquor Commission
um Jim larivier from our office will
present the audit
and joining us from the commission is uh
chairman Malika
yep
it's okay
and James Farr is also here from
director of administration
so with that James Jim will present the
the audit report
good afternoon chairman Weiler and
members of the committee again for the
record my name is Jim larivier senior
audit manager with the office of
legislative budget assistance
we're here to present the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission fiscal year 2022
management letter
if you turn to the table of contents
you'll note that this report contains
three internal control observations
none that are identified as a material
weakness and one state compliance
observation
the commission concurred in part with
two and concurred with two
the state compliance observation is
identified with an asterisk suggesting
that legislative action may be required
the observations begin over on page
three
observation number one discusses the
ongoing risk from continued continued
delays encountered while replacing the
commission's 35 year old Legacy system
mapper with a new system next-gen
resulting in a strain on staff resources
increased project costs and increase
risk to the operations
the commission's Endeavor to replace its
mapper system began in fiscal year 2016
with an estimated 24-month time frame
since then multiple plan go live dates
have not been achieved the commission
reports the risk of implementing the
next-gen system are currently greater
than the risk of continuing operations
with its current mapper system until
numerous issues described in the
bulleted items on page three
with the next gen implementation can be
resolved
we recommend number one the commission
consider and respond to risks posed by
its Reliance on its limited retired
staff resources that support its mapper
system
while continued delays and other issues
are resolved with the implementation of
the next-gen system
and two the commission seek additional
resources to fulfill its information
technology needs to ensure that they are
receiving and acting upon the best
available advice in the implementation
of its next-gen system
turning to page six observation number
two
we recommend the commission continue to
develop a formal and documented risk
assessment procedure for recognizing
evaluating and responding to risks that
could affect its ability to achieve its
financial accounting and Reporting
information technology and overall
business operation objectives
a similar recommendation was made in the
2020 Liquor Commission management letter
in observation number three on page
seven we recommend the commission revamp
its current internal audit roles and
work towards the implementation of
traditional internal audit function that
performs Audits and focuses on risk
mitigation and strengthening internal
controls
for the organization
the internal audit function should
include a formalized process including
planned procedures reporting of
weaknesses and internal control and
non-compliance and recommendations to
address the deficiencies noted
internal Auditors should have
appropriate training education and
professional background to perform
internal audit activities
the recommendation was originally
reported in the 2019 Liquor Commission
management letter
observation number four on page nine our
final and state compliance observation
recommends the commission comply with
statutes Inc the comp and its
computation of its transfer to the
alcohol Abuse Prevention and treatment
fund
the commission's fiscal year 2022
transfer was calculated based on fiscal
year 2020's gross profit not fiscal year
2021 as statutorily required
this resulted in an understatement in
the amount transferred of 1.2 million
for fiscal year 2022.
if the commission believes its current
practice of using audited gross profit
from two fiscal years prior is a better
alternative to determine its transfer
than we recommend it seek statutory
revision
current status of Prior audit findings
for fiscal years 2021 and 2020 begin on
page 11 located behind the tab
of the combined seven comments contained
in those reports
four are fully resolved and three were
in the process of being remediated
this concludes my presentation I'd like
to thank the Liquor Commission for their
assistance and cooperation during the
audit and with your permission chairman
Wylie I would like to turn the
presentation over to Chairman Mullica
for any comments that he may have
thank you very much Jim
Mr chairman members of the committee
Joseph Malika chairman of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission our CEO
James ver is here with me Tina Demir is
our CFO could not be here today and
behind me are Deputy Commissioner Nicole
brassard Jordan and project manager for
the next gen April bunker they have
worked on the project from the beginning
and we'd like to thank Jim and his team
for the work that they've done I think
we're running in competition with
lottery for the most audited and happy
to have happy to have them there and
learn something every year from them
being there so truly appreciate it
sincerely happy to answer any questions
that that the committee may have thank
you
Senator gray for a question
um certainly I have concerned over
observation number one uh started in I
think it's 16 was what the testimony is
I'm sure that that's the bullet that I
see in the bottom of page 11.
um and I guess you know looking into the
budget season uh that's coming up when
you'll be in front of Senate Finance I
certainly want to know more about this
why from 16 to present uh that uh
I haven't seen more progress in in
replacing that system or what your plan
of action milestone for this item here
on bottom of page 11 is and so that's a
heads up for you and for the
administrative Services Department in
the back that that apparently has some
control over the computer systems
I he I think he's he's saying that I'm
I'm not Iraq but we'll we'll find out
but that it will be a significant
interest item that I have you know when
we look into your budget why that
particular item is taken as long as it
has
very much Senator thank you senator
representative leishman for a question
thank you minute uh thank you Mr
chairman uh
so I had a couple of questions but I'll
go through the chair if that's all right
so going to page eight I was kind of
curious about your response at the
bottom of that section where it says the
commission will revamp existing internal
audit functions as soon as observation
one and two can be suitably
addressed that seems awful vague to me
suitably addressed can you tell me what
that means
as chairman Malika indicated my name is
James bear I'm director of
administration official so uh I worked
on this this finding so I certainly can
talk about it uh clearly so as as we've
as you've seen from audit uh
recommendation number one next-gen is a
member project that's been going on for
a long period of time now uh represent
number two discussed um a position that
was has now actually been posted I have
not had the opportunity to talk to Jim
larvier about that so we're we're
actually going through a new process now
so when I came on board in September
I've been the commission for longer than
that but in my current position
September of last year we had some
staffing changes which included a
position the senior audit analysis
position we've now posted that position
this is all going to be a new
comprehensive view of how all of these
things work all these things have to
work in concert with one I think we all
could would agree would agree with that
all these things have to work in concert
with one another so I would not say it's
vague I would say that this is a a
project that's in in full form right so
we've now posted the position I'm now in
this position we had turnover of my
position my current position and also
the person who had the position before
now I had the opportunity to take a deep
dive in how that position was run we
want this to now work in concert with
we're now going to have a position
that's going to look at as we know there
was the performance audit that was done
on the enforcement division that was the
first of the ERM that we that we looked
at we're now going to do a comprehensive
review of the entire office with this
position with audit position coming in
but part of that has to also look at how
next-gen is going to work NextGen is a
fully formed project it's it's from
point A to point Z of how the commission
runs its business
all these things are going to work in
concert with one or like I said and part
of that is going through all of these
things now me being in this position
for other question Mr chairman thank you
so I've been on division one for I think
eight terms and I have to say that
during those eight terms there always
seems to be some kind of a delay we have
other departments that work with doit
things move more smoothly I assume that
you're real I know you're relatively new
there but I just want to express my
concern as you already heard from
Senator gray that he's going to take a
bite at your budget coming up but it
just seems there's always a delay or an
excuse I'm sorry but that's what I've
seen in my years on division one and it
it troubles me if I could Mr chairman I
go to the alcohol Abuse Prevention
calculation there seems to be a
disagreement with the Liquor Commission
and what statute says and that fund
isn't getting properly funded apparently
based on what I'm reading here so what's
that all about so I could I actually
have history with that prior to my time
being at the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission I was the drug
so I'm familiar with how that statute
was going to be implemented right if you
would as you would remember it was never
fully funded right well the liquor
liquor foam was never fully funded now
there was a change of it being funded
and how those funds would be would be uh
put in in a sort of bank right I would
say that 176.16 there's not a difference
in how 170 16 is run it was done during
a different different period of time of
how the Liquor Commission was supposed
to put the money in right week we talked
with Das we also talked with the LBA we
also talked with
um HHS excuse me HHS related of how this
should be done we of course do not want
to violate any statute that you know
I've been I've been a lawyer now for
many oh shoot I was going to say I would
say 18 years actually 20 years uh 20
years coming up you know we were
certainly in no way shape or form want
to violate any statute but in
consultation with those three groups we
wanted to ensure that we we want to we
want to put the appropriate money in I
think we have if if there is concern and
there is and we've talked to the the LBA
about it we talked about it when
actually it was currently being done and
now we'll just ask for a statutory roll
request a statutory change I think that
would then satisfy any concerns I I want
to first though say at no point in time
have we ever not provided the funding
for the alcohol fund we've always done
it appropriately the money that was
requested to be in there has always made
it there so if there's any concerns of
it being somehow an excuse of some way
shape or form I want to dissuade any of
those concerns because I certainly have
not seen that in my time at the
commission nor would I say that chairman
Mullica would have seen that as well
now related to the the next gem project
we certainly have the people here that
can talk about it but I certainly can
outline a few of the things that have
happened we had a prior vendor Alpha
people that did not go through uh we we
made the right fiscal decision to end
our relationship with them we now have
blue horseshoe which is done a
oh I'm sorry I apologize I apologize
representative so I you know we now are
at the point where we further along than
ever before we certainly did not
anticipate a pandemic occurring we also
have had updates that are required
updates from Microsoft we've also had
you know and I think dot would I know
they would agree with this we had
Staffing challenges it's related to doit
you know we've had things that certainly
were no fault of the liquor commissions
that ended up being you know a delay and
I think they're I think the team here
today would say this unequivocally there
is no group that wants this project to
be up and running more than us
and I think I I would say with with uh
some level of assurance that we
anticipate fiscal year
2024 that the project will be up and
running
I just want to add representative the
caveat has always been
the risk the risk versus the reward do
we really want to put the revenue of the
Liquor Commission at risk to to be on
time with a project that could possibly
be faulty the answer to me is no the the
revenue that we create every year is
essential to the state of New Hampshire
and this old system that we have is a
working system do we go with a new
system when we're not 100 sure of it in
my mind we don't and that's one of the
one of the cautionary tales that we've
always been through with this we've
we've been pressured to launch and we
aren't going to launch until we can
assure everyone
that the revenue will not be disturbed
for the question
Senator Rosenwald thank you hi
commissioner and Mr rare it's really
nice to see you again
um I have a few questions if I could so
going back to what Senator gray started
on the next-gen system am I reading
correctly on page four that we've
already put 20 million into this
what is the full
cost we're expecting
when it's finally running I mean are we
talking mmis here
yes feel free to use that Mike
April bunker is the project manager
Senator she can answer that question for
you
so we are as as director Vera said we're
farther along than we've ever been we're
now talking about support post go live
we're talking about performance testing
to make sure that
um although the processes are working
that they can handle the sales volume
that we have and and the the volume of
of you know product movement that we we
have at the commission and again as he
said this this touches every piece of
our business from A to Z
it has unfortunately cost us more money
simply because we've had the failed
vendor for the three years we are
feeling like we're Incredibly Close we
do anticipate one additional Amendment
which will require additional funding
but um we're almost there
can I follow up thank you so
I'm sure we'll be hearing how much that
additional funding is but on the
transfer to the Alcohol and Other Drug
fund
if we're missing 1.2 million is the
commission going to be transferring that
this fiscal year or next fiscal year and
when you say you're seeking revision of
RSA
17616 are you doing that in-house Bill
too we have not really we have not asked
for a statutory change at this point
obviously this happened you know fairly
recently of when we're here in that
audit uh finding we certainly could you
know I don't think there is any harm to
that well we concur so be in touch yeah
but will you be transferring that money
when that's our understanding that we
would be the CFO would certainly be
better equipped to answer that but I
there's no we will be we will be putting
the money into the fund
as we have as we had previously had
there's no question that we will be
putting the funding in
the other because there's not 1.2
million missing it's just times of when
it has been put in
okay thank you
representative Edwards for a question so
uh this is just to address Senator
rosenwald's issue just so you know that
for the uh 24 25 budget the division
three is just done with now we we did
increase on an HP one item with some HD
hb2 language uh the the full amount of
money to make up the five percent so so
we've I think in the future
we'll we'll be budgeting it accurately
representative erf for a question
so I had previously read your the very
last paragraph on page 10. and it's I
guess maybe I'm interpreting it
differently but it seems to imply that
your change is going to
change legislative change the legis
change the law to match what you're
doing
is that a misunderstanding or misreading
of that it would change it to how we are
currently doing with advice from Das HHS
as well as LBA so with that
understanding wouldn't that mean you're
not going to transfer
the one whatever it is that amount
because your current understanding as I
read this implies that that would not
have been that would not be transferred
oh it would be transferred obviously the
statutory change would have to happen
after that would be transferred it would
be my understanding of it
okay so in the video
yes follow-up so I think what I just
showed you say is you'll transfer that
whatever it is but
after a legislative change when we get
to the next time you do this you're
going to do it the way that you're
you've been doing it so you wouldn't
have transferred those funds is that
accurate
it's a it's a hypothetical that we're
sort of is not the funds will be
transferred as required by Statute we
will ensure that that
flooding mandate happens I understand
that that's not my question are you Chan
are you playing so you say you're gonna
you're in a legislative change I'm
understood that correctly right yes okay
are you changing it such that
the effect would be to
pay based on the current year not two
years prior or are you changing it so
it'll be based on the two years prior
we haven't even gone that far yet we
certainly would would ask for any any
input we would certainly work with the
LBA on that as well uh you know my what
is here you know I I would venture to
say that we would be paying it as we've
currently been paying it okay I I just
think
Senator rosenwald's point it doesn't
sound like your verbiage is expressing
that in that last paragraph there
I apologize for any misinterpretation
and we would certainly continue to
follow bang as we're required to
Mike
Mr Kane sure and and we'll continue to
work with the legislature throughout the
budget process it really is a timing
issue of what information is available
and what the Liquor Commission is
statutorily
um
required to do versus the actual timing
of a fiscal year because as you know we
just got a presentation of fiscal year
um on the actual kafir and so that's
what they'd have to use but they don't
have to they won't be able to know that
figure until you're doing your budget
for 24. so it's that two-year lag it's
the very stringent requirement and
statute right now to use the kafir
figures but I'm sure that as we go
through the process with the legislature
uh working with the Liquor Commission
and we could probably come up with
something
representative leishman did you want to
add something yeah thank you Mr chairman
so I guess just to direct address the
Chairman's comment about raising money
and you don't want that anything to get
in the way of raising money but I just
want to say we want to make sure
everything is is as transparent as
possible and I want to read something
somebody mentioned I think Senator Greg
gray rather about the budget
um you just one of you just said that
you're trying to get this next-gen
system up and running you've had some
issues with it what division one did
is uh the Liquor Commission came before
us for some additional priorities
and we provided a supported 1.9 million
dollars for next gen for 24.
and 1.5 million for 25.
and this is for and let me read it here
maintenance and support of the next gen
system so I'm kind of concerned when you
say you're having trouble getting it up
and things haven't worked out but you're
asking for millions of dollars for the
maintenance and continued support of the
system in your prioritized request so I
just hope the Senate takes a good look
at this as well because I just as I said
earlier I've had concerns for years
about what is said and what isn't said
well I can assure you representative
that there's nothing that's not
transparent at The Liquor Commission
we've been audited every year and our
audit findings have been have turned
into a minimalistic audit findings with
all due respect and we work very hard to
make sure
that the revenue to this state is safe
and sound and one of the concerns with
launching next-gen prior to it being
ready is the concern of the revenue and
the revenues that you're speaking to in
the budget that we've asked for are for
one once the uh program is launched we
understand that every program such as uh
administrative service is doing now with
they've asked for 20 million dollars to
upgrade their system Microsoft changes
these systems as you go along and these
types of
prioritized needs and upgrades have to
happen we've been running with a system
that was homemade
for 35 or 40 years and has cost the
state nothing other than the employees
that ran it and what we're moving to is
a complete cloud-based system and those
cloud-based systems have licenses and
they have they have expeditious spending
that has to take place in order to keep
them current and that will be an ongoing
thing from from this point forward from
when next-gen launches that the state
will have to incur
thank you
I I just don't want to be argumentative
Mr chairman but I'm just reading from
their prioritized lists and it's for the
maintenance and continued support of the
next-gen system
as we heard earlier from the project
manager it's it's a it's in progress and
obviously the
the big thing and we see a lot of the
theft through the cloud of many banks
and many financial institutions and I I
support your caution
because someone would love to steal a
few million right out of it so
Senator gray thank you just a final
comment from me I guess you know if I
look at representative leishman and
myself and some of the others you know a
detailed plan of action milestones and
how you are accomplishing those will
answer a lot of our questions okay and
that is one of the things that you know
I expect to see you know when we're
doing the budget and when we're talking
about this particular item so you know
that's
the kind of thing that I'm interested in
hopefully that'll answer you know the
representatives questions my questions
and we will either provide the oversight
or have doit provide the oversight of
you know the things that are going on
there and try to help you along to get
it up and running and and working for
everyone
we have a timeline right here Senator
that we'd be happy to pass out and this
project is has been done from the
beginning in concert with Das doit and
the department of safety Rick Bailey
Charlie is on our board Dennis is on our
board as well as myself and others
thank you
did the project manager want to add
anything I did want to just stress that
we have gone live with certain pieces of
the next-gen system which was the second
recommendation of the LBA in the in the
report we have gone live with a very
profitable b2c
program that was part of this this
initial next-gen project that was split
apart from the Dynamics Microsoft
Dynamics project when the first vendor
failed so anything that can be
implemented we've implemented electronic
sales tags which saves labor costs in
our stores we've implemented EMV
compliant or the chip compliant pin pads
all of our stores have the new Hardware
in them so there are many pieces of the
next gen project that have gone live I
just wanted to make sure that we're
stressing that that we have done done
that and and we anticipate that Dynamics
is going to be able to go live in the
very near future thank you Senator gray
if you'd get on my calendar call Debbie
and whoever else in the department you
want to take with you I would be
interested in in what the expansion of
this this last block which is on your
plan of action Milestones is so that I
can understand that because it's
certainly not detailed enough for me to
do anything more with than just say well
gee Yep they're working on it so I
appreciate it thank you thank you Center
further questions from the committee
we've already had a motion to accept the
reports place them on file and release
in the usual manner are you ready for
that question
seeing no further question
I'll entertain your vote on that motion
all in favor say aye
oppose no
motion can't
thank you gentlemen good luck on your
progress we'll look forward to hearing
about it and the good work of the of the
audit division as usual gentlemen
appreciate all your work
thank you representative Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you very
much
Mr Kane
if you have anything else to add nothing
else to add just the day to the next
meeting uh the third Friday in April is
the 21st
um we'll be in a much easier position in
this in the house but I know the Senate
will be busy any restrictions on when
you want to meet that day
Financial meet that afternoon
performance every Friday afternoon
certain selections
certainly the the schedule right now
um isn't cast in concrete and that if I
need to to carve out a couple of hours
for fiscal uh we will certainly do that
so we have nothing in the morning why
don't we go back to our normal morning
we could do it in the morning if it if
it works for us sounds sounds good to me
how early
10 o'clock
all right next meeting will be April
21st at 10 o'clock of the fiscal
committee and we appreciate all the
people that attended today and all your
inputs especially the audit division I
didn't think
John there so I want him to know that I
appreciate his efforts as well
silver
and
commissioner arlinghaus thank you for
staying long term in case we needed some
advice
thank you foreign
anything further to come before the
fiscal committee
seeing none
I'll entertain a motion to adjourn
motion and a second to adjourn all in
favor say aye
we are adjourned